- Time management type
stuff, that's something
we've got to hang on eventually.
Ah, that comes with time.
Oh.
What?
- Are you serious
- Fuck.
- Hysteric?
No!
Derek, what the hell?
- [Seated man] What are you?
- I was working on that.
I have to do the fucking reports!
- That's a computer.
So just, yeah, keep that in mind and uh.
- Jack is probably like
the grossest guy at work,
I think, three day old
sandwich on my desk.
Yeah man, Jack's just like
probably one of the grossest
guys in the office,
(mumbling through food)
clean you know, like,
(smacking sound)
- Oh shit!
- You just slapped me.
You just friggin' slapped me, man!
Yeah, I mean I'm not wrong in this Derek,
am I, Jack's like probably
one of the grossest guys.
- Hey Derek, do you have those copies
that they were talking about?
- Shhh.
Shut your beautiful mouth.
- Why don't you make me?
- Shh, shut your mouth.
Shut your beautiful mouth.
- Do you need something, Derek?
That's weird.
- [Man] Hey Derek, could you get
these figures over to Todd for me?
Thanks, champ.
Uh Derek,
So the office has sort
of noticed your getting
smashed and watching cartoons at work,
could you stop?
- What?
- Uh, Derek, you had
your presentation ready
to go, yeah?
- Yeah.
- Sure.
(light music playing)
- [Man] What?
Derek!
So yeah, those are my
favorite days of the week.
(rock music)
- You like that, you like that, hold on.
Wait, no, no, no, wait.
- Well as Todd I find this hostile.
- Fine, that way, hold on.
- That's a little better.